The joe rogan experience,
you,
you bring up some really
fascinating subjects. And, um,
we were talking right before the podcast
about social media and how weird it is
that you got lumped in with the alt right
for a comment saying something along
the lines of,
uh,
that you find what was the exact quote
is something along the highly intelligent
people seem to,
which is not saying they're good people.
No,
that's right.
And I think a lot of people who are
ignorant to the outright equate them with
the, uh, the, the skinheads and the
Neo Nazis carrying the Tiki torches.
But when I was referring strictly to the
alt right from its origin in internet
discussion groups and I, you
know, I know some of them,
someone going to former students and
some of them are highly intelligent and
highly read. So, uh, but,
but that's not what people often think
of when they think of the alt right.
And that's what I was referring
to. I, there are people in tech,
there's some people in universities
to stay under cover. And, uh, I was,
I made some remarks on how to starve
that movement. And I had to feed it.
But yeah,
so many people jumped on it as if
you were endorsing the alt right.
And what was the exact quote you were
just basically saying something along the
lines of there's a lot of
intelligent people that are involved.
Well, it wasn't so much that it was also
the fact that because of the, uh, uh,
the various taboos in mainstream
intellectual culture, the,
the cause of political correctness,
there's certain things that are
just kind of not discussable.
But then when people in the
alt right discover them,
they feel tremendously empowered.
Like we are now privy to the truth
that the establishment can't handle.
You can't handle the truth. And since
it was never discussed in the open,
there are no counter arguments to some
of the most toxic interpretations.
And so the alt right
can run with the never,
never having been in a forum where these
things are debated and criticized and
put into context,
they take like one fact and then they
draw the most extreme conclusions.
If these things were
debated in the first place,
then you'd realize that those
conclusions, uh, are not warranted. Oh,
it's from an example is there are average
differences between men and women and
a lot of psychological
traits now, uh, if that's,
and that's often quite taboo and
intellectual circles for I think bizarre
reasons.
There are people who think that somehow
women's rights depend on men and women
being a indistinguishable, right? I think
it's a bad equation in the first place,
but as soon as you come across the
fact that men and women on average are,
are different,
you also come across the fact that men
and women overlap in a lot of these
traits that whatever trait you name that
men on average are better at that women
or vice versa.
There are a lot of women who are
better than a lot of men or vice versa.
And so you can't really
judge an individual from the
average of, uh, their, their,
their sex.
Also,
even though there are some traits where
men score a little better than women,
there are some traits where women score
a little better than men and that that's
the complete picture.
But the thing is that if the
entire subject is out of bounds,
you never get to present complete picture.
And some people run away with all men
and women are totally different. What,
what are your thoughts on how the
subject got out of bounds? Because it's,
it's very confusing to
me that certain subjects,
like the differences between genders
are so taboo when they seem so obvious.
I mean,
you just could go to a mall and just look
at the way the men dress and the women
dress and you go, well, there's
some obvious distinctions here.
There's a history to it,
right? Because there were,
there were a lot of cockamamie theories
and the 19th century in a lot of the
20th century that, uh, that, that men
were intellectual and women were not.
And women were governed by
their emotions and their,
if we've been thought too much,
it would take blood away
from their ovaries and their
womb and they wouldn't be
fertile and then they'd be all miserable.
I mean, really like crazy stuff.
And as a reaction to that in the 70s,
when the second wave of
feminism became prominent,
it became almost an article of faith that
there were no differences between men
and women. Uh, and so if you
say that there are differences
between men and women,
you're sending women back to the,
to the kitchen in the nursery.
So this is a total non sequitur because
fairness is not the same as sameness.
So obviously women should
have equal rights to men,
whether or not they're exact copies of
men or have a distinctive profile as men
have a distinct profile. So I
think it was just a mistake to, uh,
to conflate the issue of women's rights
with men and women being identical.
Uh,
but that's the way it kind of shook out.
And it became kind of an article
of faith in, uh, in a lot of,
in some feminist,
some kind of left liberal circles that
men and women have to be identical.
And if they aren't, that means you're
a trader to a women's equality.
And articles of faith are always
dangerous, always dangerous,
especially in that regard. It's articles.
A fairness are always important. I mean,
fair being fair to each other
and but being fair is also
recognizing differences.
That's right. And not assuming that any
differences or deficiency, right. I mean,
if you're really doing an
honest comparison of the
differences between men and
women, men wouldn't come out looking
so good. Right. You know? Yeah.
I have a whole bit about that in my act
when we're looking at the reaction to
this though,
what was strange to me was how many
people seemed like they wanted to jump on
board and criticize you.
And I think a lot of it is almost like
to take away some of the potential
criticism of themselves.
Like it's instant claiming of the
moral high ground virtue signaling.
And it's just very disappointing when
you see this from intellectuals and
college professors and it is, it
should know better. I mean, to be fair,
I did not get into much
trouble from, from, you know,
my peers and among up professors
and Grad students and so on.
There are a couple of trolls who, uh,
who, who ran with it. But by and large,
the mainstream reaction was that
this was almost a sign of a,
as a New York Times put it.
The social media is making a stupid yeah.
That was the article.
The cover,
the name of the title of the article in
The Times. Yeah. So it was by and large,
uh, you know, I came out of it. Okay.
But it wasn't real indication of how these
mobs of outrage can corrupt Andy kind
of intelligent discourse.
Yeah. We'll subtle discussions.
The discussions that involve nuance
like complicated issues that are there.
They're complex.
They require a long sort of
description of the issue and I'll,
I'll, I'll, uh, very
okay.
Complex sort of take on these various
differences between men and women and the
alt right and the left and
political. Correct. These are,
these are long discussions.
I mean,
these aren't some thing that you can
smash into a very short soundbite and
completely cover your take on things hold
the more reason that they shouldn't be
taboo,
because if you can't discuss them,
then the only interpretation you're
going to have as the simplistic one,
if you could bring them out in the open,
then you can start to
have that discussion.
Okay.